So let's take a look at the value proposition in a little more detail
and expand on those three components.
The first one is your product, and as we said earlier,
"You need to understand which are part of your value proposition."
Is it just hardware or software or books or are there really some manufacturing goods,
some commodities, are you going to have intangible products that are part,
copyrights and licenses that are part of your value proposition
or are your going to have any financial products that is guarantees or insurance policies
or maintenance contract or you're going to add some digital features to it as well.
What we point here is that you realize that your product and service is not just the bits or hardware,